[Musica]
vi è mai capitato di dover imparare a
fare qualcosa e di dover imparare a
farlo pensateci
a me è successo l'anno scorso è dovuto
rimparare a disegnare questo per me è
stato un problema perché il disegno è il
mio lavoro io creo ambientazioni
immaginarie
io sono una concept artist anche se la
maggior parte della gente non ha la più
pallida idea di che cosa sia la concept
art provate ad immaginare a un
videogioco un film di fantascienza al
signore degli anelli o al trono di spade
ambientazioni architetture paesaggi
tutto ciò che non esiste nella realtà
qualcuno dovrà prima pensarlo e poi
disegnarlo e poi qualcun altro si
occuperà di farlo in 3d
io sono quella persona che pensa e
disegna la maggior parte del mio lavoro
e creare quelle che in gergo si chiamano
familles miniature sono delle vere e
proprie esplorazioni infatti esplorano
come la luce se epica oppure soffusa
dove sono posizionate le camere
quali sono le lenti focali come e dove
questo paesaggio
bisogna essere molto veloce nel folle
perché spesso se ne presentano parecchie
giusto per non lasciare niente di
intentato
una volta scelta quella vincente la si
porta avanti e la si dettaglia sempre di
più per renderla pronta per la
produzione finale ci vogliono anni per
imparare a fare questo mestiere e anni
per allenare la mano a fare una serie di
gesti e movimenti ma come vi dicevo
prima
ho dovuto imparare a fare tutto ciò
torniamo per un minuto nel 2019
ero a grigliare con amici quando ancora
lo si poteva fare e appunto in quel
momento ho iniziato a sentire uno strano
fastidio al braccio
ho passato tutto il giorno a muovermi la
maglia credendo che fosse quella darmi
fastidio però il giorno dopo arrivato
uno strano intorpidimento alle gambe e
poi non l'ho più sentite chiaramente
sono andato in panico e quindi ho subito
contattato un medico che mi ha
prescritto una risonanza magnetica dopo
20 giorni
ho avuto referto sclerosi multipla è una
malattia cronica neurodegenerativa e non
c'è cura sclerosi multipla
provate ad immaginare a un cavo
elettrico con la sua bella guaina di
gomma che è la mielina che è il la
guaina delle fibre nervose a un certo
punto il mio sistema immunitario decide
di impazzire di attaccare questa mia
linea e di lasciare le fibre nervose
scoperto in alcuni punti è così come
succede per il cavo elettrico
se non c'è più protezione il sistema
nervoso centrale
fa fatica a diffondersi dando una serie
di sintomi diversi da persona a persona
e talvolta anche invalidanti
dopo la diagnosi sinceramente non mi è
crollato il mondo addosso ma di certo
sono atterrata su un altro pianeta
anzi sono entrate in quella che io
chiamo il multiverso un universo
parallelo completamente diverso da
quello che conoscevo ma nella realtà
pensate che 188 persone su 100 mila ogni
anno in italia vengono diagnosticati di
sclerosi multipla
beh per me è stato assolutamente come
vincere il biglietto della lotteria del
multiverso della sfiga
e a proposito di sfiga dopo sei mesi ho
avuto un'altra brutta ricaduta che ha
colpito proprio quella la mia mano
dominante
l'unico strumento di lavoro per un
lavoro che tra l'altro io amo moltissimo
fare la mia mano aveva totalmente perso
sensibilità avevo la forza ma non avevo
il grip l'aderenza insomma è qualsiasi
cosa provavo a prendere in mano quella
scivolava da tutte le parti
un'altra cosa molto strana stava
succedendo non riuscivo a capire la
posizione delle mie dita nello spazio
e assurdo da spiegare ma mentre io
guardavo la mia mano a palmo aperto e
cavolo la vedevo che la palma aperto
l'informazione che arrivava la mia mente
che le dita fossero chiuse e accavallate
luna alle altre
io non riuscivo nemmeno a capire se la
mia mamma era appoggiata a qualcosa
oppure no
provate per un secondo ad immaginarvi e
di andare a dormire le tormentate sopra
la vostra mano di svegliarvi è di non
sentirla più dopo pochi minuti che la
muovete questa attorno a funzionare
ecco a me non è successo in quel momento
avevo tra diversi clienti un sacco di
deadline un sacco di lavoro è un sacco
di responsabilità e ho capito con quello
che mi era successo che avevo solo due
strade
soltanto due la prima era dire tutto i
miei clienti non consegnare e mandare a
quel paese la mia carriera
il secondo invece era seguire la mia
testardaggine e vedere se c'era una
soluzione a questo problema
così ho messo a punto degli esperimenti
chiamiamoli creativi il primo è stato
legarmi le dita tra di loro come un
semplice elastico per provare a tenerlo
in posizione e poi ho provato ad
afferrare la mano quella scivolava da
tutte le parti il secondo un pochino più
drastico anche perché il tempo stringeva
mi sono scocciata la penna direttamente
alla mano col nastro adesivo così
rimaneva bella ferma in posizione una
delle prime cose che si imparano il mio
lavoro anche il movimento del disegno
viene dalla spalla quindi top
poi la funzionava alla grande ho
rischiato di bucare la tavoletta grafica
perché non riusciva ovviamente ad usare
la mia forza avevo perso tutte le idee
non sa più che cosa fare ero disperata e
i clienti continua a mandarmi mail
perché volevano risultati chiaramente e
quindi che cosa fare internet ho trovato
questo metodo un pochino complesso
sempre con una penna scocciata alla mano
hanno preso un'altra nell'altra mano ne
avevo due e lo connessa con un semplice
spago da cucina più o meno a questa
distanza è utilizzato la mano non
dominante per trascinare la mano che non
funzionava più
come potete ben capire queste stato il
più grande fallimento
ovviamente non è servito a un tubo
però mi ha insegnato una cosa molto
molto importante
io ho due mani quindi perché non provare
ad utilizzare l'altra
io avevo molta paura soprattutto la
paura di fallire perché so che ci
vogliono le quattro mesi in su con la
mano non dominante per riuscire più o
meno a scrivere in modo leggibile e io
di certo non avevo tutto quel tempo però
sono una persona testarda e quindi ci ho
provato lo stesso ho preso dal quaderno
e ha iniziato a riempirlo di
dalla fab eto'o a b c d dopo pochi
minuti i risultati erano agghiaccianti
ma dopo qualche ora insomma riuscivo a
scrivere bene top
peccato che io dovevo disegnare non
scrivere e quindi niente ho lasciato
cadere le mie paranoie le mie paure non
avevo assolutamente altre alternative e
quindi l'ho fatto ci ho provato e ho
provato a disegnare con la mano non
dominante la mia sinistra
i risultati sono stati incredibili sono
riuscite a disegnare molto meglio che a
scrivere e mi sono resa conto che mi
stavo appoggiando alla magica
neuroplasticità praticamente il mio
cervello in condizioni totalmente
diverse
cercavo di apprendere in modo veloce
questo non sta a significare che insomma
stava riparando qualcosa che non
funzionava più
ma che insomma cercava delle strade
diverse per superare l'ostacolo
i risultati sono stati buoni però
chiaramente non sono stati perfetti ero
più lenta ero più imprecisa pro sono
riuscita a consegnare ai miei clienti
non si sono accorti di nulla
ok probabilmente se ne accorgeranno
adesso mentre sto parlando
però diciamo che è andata tutto bene ce
l'ho fatta
adesso che la mia mano fortunatamente
perché non è scontato è tornata a
funzionare
alleno sempre l'altra mano facendo le
parole crociate i disegnini mentre sono
il telefono ma chiaramente tutto il
resto delle cose le faccio con la mia
mano dominante
però so che quando un'altra ricaduta
arriverà perché arriverà io avrò gli
strumenti per poterlo affrontare e anche
per continuare a produrre arte e perché
no per continuare a sentirmi normale
dopo questa esperienza ho voluto andare
oltre e provare a raccontare i sintomi
invisibili di questa patologia
un grosso e intendimento della sclerosi
multipla e credere che se una persona
dopo poco tempo dalla diagnosi non
finisca su una sedia a rotelle significa
che insomma la patologia non sia poi
così grave
stai bene se in piedi cambini fai tutto
va tutto bene
io direi tutto bene un corno perché uno
prova anche dentro una serie di sintomi
anche molto invalidanti
provate per un momento a pensare alla
perdita della vista per lungo periodo
oppure alla perdita dell'equilibrio
costante o non lo so
alla perdita della sensibilità che non
vi fa fare le cose quotidiane
ecco questi sono sintomi invisibili e
non hanno un linguaggio che non sia il
linguaggio degli ospedali dei plichi
alti così dei referti medici
oppure quello di google e ho voluto
appunto crearne uno diverso e l'ho fatto
con quello che so fare
il disegno ho creato 9 concept e spero
che potranno essere di più su 9 sintomi
differenti giusto appunto per renderli
visivi li ho fatti che possano essere
non troppo cupi e non sono figurativi
quindi non rappresentano persone che
provano i sintomi ma sono delle metafore
con dei paesaggi questo per esempio
rappresenta la mia insensibilità ed è
quindi la città distopica con in fondo
una statua assolutamente fuori scala
voluto e sorretta delle catene che sta
proprio a significare la difficoltà di
movimento oppure un'altra metafora che
utilizzato è la foresta e questa è la
rappresentazione del mi ami e lina di
quello che in questo momento sta
succedendo al mio sistema nervoso
centrale
proprio adesso mentre vi sto parlando
quello che vorrei chiedervi s avete
avuto dei problemi o se avete dei
problemi che sono piccoli o grandi con i
miei
provate ad andare oltre provate a perché
no a sbatterci la testa perché no ad
inventare dei nuovi esperimenti creativi
non lasciate perdere mai non fate che
questi problemi possano limitare le cose
che voi amate fare e se invece avete dei
talenti utilizzateli se avete dei
talenti ad esempio ho usato il disegno
ma se avete dei talenti diversi e
sicuramente li avrete perché non li
mettete al servizio delle altre persone
per fare qualcosa di diverso
quindi non importa con quale tempo con
quali talenti non importa
insomma le vostre capacità l'importante
è che voi ci proviate quindi proviamoci
grazie
[Applauso]